New York prepares for a coronavirus
tsunami as other major cities build
their sea walls new information suggests
coronavirus may be far less deadly than
originally suspected and president from
moles over how to reopen the economy i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't let others track what you do keep
yourself safe at expressive VPN comm
slash bet and go check mad expressvpn
dot-com slash man alrighty so we bring
you all of the updates the biggest
update of course is that the u.s. now
leads the world and confirmed a
coronavirus cases and members of the
media are going nuts over this the
United States we're number one that was
trending on Twitter yesterday wow we're
number one
people suggesting that this shows that
America really is a third world country
Julia Jaffe the execrable columnist for
GQ she actually tweeted out who's the
bleep old country now who's the bleep
out that of course supposed to be making
fun of President Trump who suggested he
didn't want people immigrating from
bleep whole countries because they might
not actually be the best American
citizens depending on the culture from
which they came again that was very
controversial comment at the time and
poorly expressed by the president but
let's just put it this way the United
States is not a bleep old country
because we have a lot of tests okay if
you were going to identify which
countries are having the hardest time
with coronavirus the United States yes
we are having a rough time with
coronavirus it is not even close to the
countries that are having the toughest
time with corn the virus how can we tell
because what doesn't matter is the
number of cases diagnosed what does
matter is the number of cases of deaths
over the number of cases a country has
right that would be a good measure and
truly because you cannot measure the
ability of a country to deal with a
crisis by simply the bottom-line number
as to how many people have experienced
the crisis it's how those people
actually recover from the crisis how
many people die so while it is true that
the United States now has the most cases
of diagnosed coronavirus that is largely
because China has undoubtedly been lying
about the coronavirus situation in China
supposedly according to China that are
having like 25 new cases of coronavirus
a day does anyone believe that literally
the day after they expelled American
journalists they apparently stopped
testing in China that is according to
sources inside China beyond that the
United States right now as of now has
about 86,000 confirmed cases of
coronavirus in the United States without
1300 deaths
okay that's not spectacular but that
means the death rate of approximately
1.3 percent Italy has eighty one
thousand cases of coronavirus and 8200
deaths so eight times as many deaths as
the United States about seven times
eight times about as many deaths as
States and fewer diagnosed cases Spain
has 64,000 diagnosed cases in nearly
5,000 deaths so the notion that the
United States is a bleep hole country
because of the number of coronavirus
diagnoses is ridiculous I mean France
has more deaths right now and they only
have 30,000 diagnosed cases by the way
nationalized healthcare systems in most
of these places so that the the kind of
triumphalism
very weird triumphalism you're seeing
from the media well now that the United
States has the most coronavirus cases
that demonstrates that the United States
is the worst country or alternatively at
Emin straits that you don't understand
maths maybe we have the worst math
programs in the country because you
idiots don't understand what a numerator
and a denominator are in terms of
determining rates but with that said
again the United States is dealing with
this thing so far and the big question
is going to be whether coronavirus
overcomes the capacity of the healthcare
system that has been the question for a
long time I've been talking about on the
program for weeks at this point let me
talk about flattening the curve the
point of flattening the curve is not
that everyone will not eventually get
coronavirus and all likelihood everyone
will eventually get coronavirus the
question is whether that swamps our
capacity to deal with it and right now
it is unclear exactly how much we are
going to be swamped because we're seeing
reports that suggest we're gonna be
swamped the media obviously are trying
to kind of get ahead of those reports we
saw Casey hunt over at NBC News tweet
out earlier today that hospitals were
already making decisions about who would
get events later and who would not
except for the fact that hospitals are
not actually doing that at this point
right and and so the notion that we are
like being overwhelmed right now right
the second we don't know that yet
there been these forecasts that we were
gonna get overrun by earlier this week I
remember Andrew Cuomo suggest that by
Tuesday New York City's hospital's ICU
beds their ventilators were gonna be
overwhelmed and then the suggestion was
that by today by Friday that the New
York system was going to be overwhelmed
and we'll see whether it is indeed
overwhelmed although the reality is that
most of the New York public officials
are saying right now that they are not
overwhelmed right that is as things
stand at current but the United States
does lead the world and confirm
coronavirus cases because we are ramping
up testing which is good thing we should
be ramping up testing you wanna get back
to work you want to know how bad this
thing is we need more testing and we
need tests of blood blood serum we need
to know whether people have developed
the antibodies
because one of the things that we're
trying to figure out right now is just
how deadly this thing is what exactly
are the death rates and that is
something and by the way my system I
strongly suspect then not tens of
thousands not hundreds of thousands but
millions of Americans actually have had
coronavirus that is it that is my deep
suspicion not just my suspicion by the
way this is fiction of virtually
everybody who has taken a look at these
numbers yesterday we had on a doctor
from from Stanford University suggesting
that he thinks that if you take the
number of people broadly speaking across
the United States who have had corner
virus or do have corner virus and don't
know about it and experience no symptoms
or mild symptoms and then moved on with
their life if you take that number and
you take the number of deaths over the
actual number of people who have had or
do have corona virus you're looking at a
death rate that actually does look much
more akin to the fluid now that's not
mean you're not gonna see more absolute
death in the United States because if
300 million people get it and it has the
same death rate as the flu you are still
going to end up with like five times as
many people dying from that as from the
flu because every season in the United
States get about 50 60 million people
with the flu if instead you had 300
million people with the flu more people
on an absolute level will die this is
how percentages work but the reason I
suspect this is because you're seeing a
lot of prominent people come down with
this thing right Boris Johnson the Prime
Minister of Great Britain announced
today that he has mild symptoms of
corona virus and he tested positive for
corona virus so the question becomes why
is it that all of these problems and
people are getting corona virus right at
the NBA or a bunch of people have corona
virus you're seeing celebrities like Tom
Hanks and Rita Wilson have corona virus
you're seeing fairly famous people come
down with corona virus so the question
is is this thing that is this a thing
that like only famous people are getting
or alternatively is it that in a time of
a shortage of testing is it possible the
only people who are getting tests are
the celebrities right which is probably
the accurate assessment of the situation
right the NBA was getting early tests
because all those people are rich and
famous and celebrities and they have
hook ups with doctors and they can get a
connect so it's not that only NBA
players are getting it or that only
Prime Minister Boris Johnson is getting
it it's they you may have had it or you
might have had it but you didn't get a
test because you're not famous and
because the tests are hard to come by
okay so according to the New York Times
the United States - the world's third
most populous nations of course that's
not a shock that we also have the
world's highest number of coronavirus
cases and also it's difficult to compare
the United States to like it
right Italy has nearly as many cases as
we do and they have 60 million people we
have 330 million people so on a per
capita basis we're not even close to
number one on a per capita basis we're
somewhere in the middle of the pack
actually in terms of diagnosed
coronavirus cases if you took the United
States versus that you which is closer
to apples to apples then you would be
looking at the EU just swamping the
United States and as I say China is
number one in terms of population India
is number two in terms of population we
have no actual data on it I think it's I
think that's right I think China it's
more than India but it's pretty close in
any case we don't actually have any data
from India and China has been lying
about their data so we don't actually
know if the United States is number one
that hit again it's not stopping people
in the media from suggesting that this
is because the United States is uniquely
weird and evil and all this very we're
the same people who will accuse
religious Americans of having this
apocalyptic view of the United States
accuse the religious Americans it's
sitting around going well God is sending
a plague on this cruel nation right
those same people are sitting around
going well the United States we're bleep
old country we sort of had this coming
didn't we we sort of deserved it they
have this very weird sort of quasi
religious view that mother nature is
taking her revenge in some sort of vague
sense it's very weird
okay well we'll get some more of this in
just one second because there is good
news today and there's bad news today
we're gonna get to the bad news first
and then we'll get to some of the good
news is to where things stand because
again there's a lot of data floating
around they're gonna try to go through
all of it the theme of the show if you
haven't noticed for the past several
weeks is I don't know and you don't know
and anybody who claims they know is
lying to you okay so when you watch the
media and you watch the media's
narrative on this thing evolve in
real-time understand that's because the
data is moving around some people can be
honest about that and some people gonna
lie to you about that we're gonna be
honest about that and just we don't know
what we don't know okay because right
now there's there's this sort of
pressure for everybody to come down hard
for it to people for people to go to
their priors to people immediately to
declare it's either a huge problem or no
problem at all and we're not gonna do
that we're just gonna give you the data
and then we're gonna you know kind of
comment on how people are reacting to it
first let us talk about the reality of
the situation right now we gotta save
every penny we can a lot of Americans
many many Americans have outstanding
credit card debt even after the
government is done floating people money
the economy is still gonna be a lot
weaker than it was just three four weeks
ago a lot of people gonna be out of work
now would be an excellent time for a
credit card consolidation loan
with a light stream credit card
consolidation loan you can get as low as
five point nine five percent APR with
Auto pay light stream believes that
people with good credit deserve a better
loan experience that's exactly what they
deliver and get a loan from five
thousand bucks to one hundred thousand
bucks there are absolutely no fees you
can even get your money as soon as the
day you apply applied today and get a
special interest rate discount save even
more the only way to get the discount no
delight stream comm / Shapiro now is an
excellent time to prep for the future to
make sure they get rid of that credit
card net cuz that will kick back in at a
certain point here light stream comm
slash Shapiro Li ght stre am calm /
capiro if you are prepping for a weaker
economy which is undoubtedly going to
come in the next few weeks and is
already hitting us then you should be
consolidating your credit cards right
now and prepping it for the future
subject to credit approval rate includes
0.50% auto pay discount terms and
conditions apply offers are subject to
change without notice
is it light Stream calm / appear o for
more information go check them out right
now light stream calm / will be
responsible about your finances
especially in this rough time okay so as
I say that was the big headline that the
United States is number one in terms of
coronavirus diagnosis but that doesn't
make a huge difference because who cares
it's really how many people die compared
to that number and whether the health
system gets of Lum the speaking of that
Scott Gottlieb who is the former Trump
head of the FDA he's become one of the
trusted voices on this thing he put out
a chart showing the emerging situations
in various American cities and how
exactly the the deaths are doubling in
New York City basically deaths are
doubling every couple of days Andrew
Cuomo suggested that that is starting to
to flatten out that thanks to the social
distancing thanks to the lockdown that
is starting to flatten out a little bit
Michigan is is really jumping Michigan
has a very steep curve right now in
terms of the number of people who are
dying every day again there's not a lot
of data you're like four days into some
of these charts right Michigan's only
being measured after like four days
basically usually you seeing a pretty
sharp curve up in New Jersey you're
seeing a fairly sharp curve in Georgia
California for some reason is lagging
and that's interesting right Florida is
also kind of lagging and that that's
interesting as well yep there was an
article in The Associated Press asked
him why Los Angeles for example has so
many fewer diagnosed cases
than New York City part of that maybe
lack of testing part of that is
undoubtedly the fact that being a
lifelong residents of Los Angeles isn't
much more spread out town I mean New
York everybody is right on top of each
other the subways are always crowded
there are gonna be some serious
questions to be asked by the way you
know what people are talking about
Andrew Cuomo presidential candidate look
at all of his great leadership there
gonna be some fairly serious questions
to be asked to Andrew Cuomo and Mayor
Bill de Blasio if this really does get
bad in New York City as to why they were
leaving public transportation running in
the middle of all of us seriously like
why were all the subways running I mean
those are the places that are most
likely to be the areas in which people
acquire coronavirus a bunch of hard
surfaces in small areas underground
right that that's gonna be what you're
noticing here by the way is that many of
the areas that are public transportation
systems are the ones that are getting
the hardest hit the people it turns out
that may be your personal protective
equipment was your car being on public
transportation is a place where you're
most likely to acquire germs Gottlieb
said I'm worried about emerging
situations in New Orleans Dallas Atlanta
Miami Detroit Chicago Philadelphia among
others New Orleans is seeing a pretty
sharp spike right now in China no
province outside who Bay ever had more
than 1,500 cases in the United States 11
states are already hit that total our
epidemic is likely to be national in
scope well it is true it's likely to be
national in scope but there are likely
to be differences by area we're gonna
get to that in just a moment meanwhile
again all eyes on New York City because
New York City is is sort of the canary
in the coalmine it is the epicenter of
the outbreak in the United States
according to the New York Times the New
York City's death toll hit 365 last
night the case count topped to 23,000
which means that somewhere between 1/3
and 1/2 of all cases in the United
States are happening in new york city
health officials reported late Thursday
the New York City had added 3,100 new
confirmed coronavirus cases since the
same time on Wednesday bringing the
total to 23,000 112 by comparison more
than 4,400 new cases were added from
Tuesday to Wednesday so maybe the curve
is starting to flatten out Chris Andrew
Cuomo had suggested that the governor
the number of virus related deaths
climbed to 365 on Thursday up from 280
the day before from Wednesday morning to
Thursday morning a hundred people died
of coronavirus in the state overall said
Andrew Cuomo at a news briefing on
Thursday he said the number of patients
hospitalized in New York had shut up 40
percent in a day which was the sharpest
increase in days he said that older and
weaker patients have been keeping on the
waiters for 20 days or longer before
they succumb to respiratory failure
failures that means that the shortages
that we're talking about are not just
number events leaders versus number of
people who are sick it is also that once
you're on events later you're staying on
events later for quite a while
he says the longer you're on a
ventilator the more probability of a bad
outcome he said the government the
governor emphasized that the numbers on
any single day did not necessarily
capture the damage being caused by the
virus he said when you talk to
projection models what they'll say is
you got a fluctuation they don't know if
it's deviation and what hospitals happen
to report that day so he says don't take
the day-by-day numbers in New York take
the the three-day averages the three
days swinging averages however Cuomo did
expressed some optimism that perhaps New
York was in fact slowing the growth of
the curve with all of that said we're
still trying to figure out where these
projections end up and it's very
difficult to tell where these
projections end up at this point there
is the suggestion that the peak is not
going to be hit until sometime in April
there's one study that came out I
mentioned it briefly yesterday from the
University of Washington School of
Medicine suggesting the corona virus
pandemic could kill more than 81
thousand people in the United States in
the next four months and might not
subside until June they say the number
of hospitalized patients is expected to
peak nationally by the second week of
April though the peak may come later in
some states because again this thing
does not spread perfectly evenly some
people could continue to die of the
virus as late as July although death
should be below epidemic levels of 10
per day by June at the latest according
to the analysis the analysis has a wide
range of outcomes ranging from as low as
38 thousand deaths so as high as 160
2,000 deaths which is why again you
should take every prediction with a
grain of salt when the range is
literally fourfold it is very difficult
to tell exactly where this thing is
going to go the variance is due in part
to disparate rates of the spread of the
virus in different regions which experts
are still struggling to explain said dr.
Christopher Murray director of the
Institute for Health metrics and
evaluation at the University of
Washington who led the study the
analysis also highlights the strain
placed on hospitals at the epidemic
speak sick patients could exceed the
number of available hospital beds by
64,000 could require the use of around
20,000 ventilators which is interesting
because that study says 20,000
ventilators New York alone has been
calling for 30 to 40,000 ventilators so
this study from the University of
Washington says that at peak you might
need 20,000 ventilators that's a that's
half of what we were being told like
days ago about the 40,000 ventilators
that we're going to be needed the the
doctors at University of Washington they
said the virus is spreading more slowly
in California they say that peak cases
there would come later in April social
distancing measures might need to be
extended in the state for longer they
expect that Louisiana and Georgia are
gonna be fairly hard-hit throughout all
of this yeah all of this has led to the
politicization of talk around
ventilators there's a story from the New
York Times about how the federal
government had supposedly canceled a
contract with GM and Ventech life
systems to produce ventilators and it
was flying around Twitter last night out
and give you the the actual story
because it's buried in like paragraph 10
of the New York Times piece according to
New York Times piece basically the Trump
administration thought ventilators were
too expensive that's not the actual
story we'll get to that in just one
second first okay right now you need to
make sure that you're hiring is as
efficient as possible you are hiring
exactly the right people you are
building for the future you got to make
sure that your company is running as
efficiently as possible and that's why
you got to cut deadweight people like
michael moles you just got to cut them
you can't have them anymore you have to
leave them on the side of the road and
you might need to find replacements and
this is where you would look to zip
recruiter to find somebody mildly more
talented than somebody like Michael
Knowles zip recruiter makes hiring great
people faster and easier today you can
try as hip recruit for free and zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire when you
head on over his hip recruiter with one
click you can send your job to zip
recruiters a network of over 100 leading
job sites what happens after that well
zip recruiter finds the best matches for
your job and then invites them to apply
it's so effective that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruit got a
quality candidate within the very first
day listen if it had been up to me I
would have listed in Michaels job on zip
recruiter literally years ago it is only
Jeremy boring my business partner who
insists like he will literally pull my
hands away from the computer using
social distancing measures using tongs
at this point to prevent me from listing
Michaels job on zip recruiter comm
because I am very well aware that zip
recruiter could find somebody more
talented right now to try zip recruiter
for free my listeners can go to zip
recruiters comm slash daily wire that is
zip recruiter comm slash Dai ly Wira zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire zip
recruiter is indeed the smartest way to
iron you need a smart way to hire these
days okay so there's a story from the
New York Times
we're going through all bad news and
we'll get you some good news so don't
worry it'll be balanced out in a moment
there's a story from the New York Times
that the Trump administration had almost
cut a deal with General Motors invent
act
Douce all of these ventilators and the
the stories by David Sanger Maggie
Haberman and so on Kendall Young's say
the White House had been preparing to
reveal on Wednesday a joint venture
between GM and Ventech life systems that
would allow for the production of as
many as 80,000 desperately needed
ventilators to respond to an escalating
pandemic when word suddenly came down
that the announcement was off now notice
it really is fascinating how variable
all these numbers are right again I go
back to my main point nobody knows
anything okay that University of
Washington study says that at peak we
might need 20,000 ventilators this story
is about how the US government was going
to try to acquire 80,000 ventilators now
listen I'd rather have too many than too
few
obviously but when you are off by you
know a factor of four in some of these
predictions it is very this is all
catch-as-catch-can it's it catches catch
hand it is incredibly sloppy and that's
just the way the life is sometimes but
let's recognize that this is not
pinpoint accuracy we have the hard data
we know what the science we don't know a
lot of things the decision to cancel the
announcement government officials say
came after FEMA said it needed more time
to assess whether the estimated cost was
prohibitive that price tag was more than
1 billion dollars with several hundred
million dollars to be paid upfront to GM
to retool a car parts plant in Kokomo
Indiana where the ventilators would be
made with vent X technology government
officials said the deal might still
happen but they're examining at least a
dozen a dozen other proposals they
contend that an initial promise that the
joint venture could turn out 20,000
ventilators in short order had shrunk to
7,500 with even that number in doubt so
that would be the actual story right the
way that the New York Times played this
and the way that the reporters tweeted
this out was that the Trump
administration was on the verge of
generating all the ventilators overnight
tomorrow and they just decided a billion
dollars is too much and so people on
Twitter were like ok hold up a second
we're spending 6 trillion dollars and
you can't find 1 billion dollars to
provide the ventilators if that's not
what's happening here
it sounds like GM couldn't even
guarantee they were gonna produce the
ventilators it sounds like they didn't
even know they're gonna produce 7500
ventilators and so the government FEMA
went back and opened up the contract and
said ok well let's get some competitive
bids in here longtime emergency managers
at FEMA are working with military
officials to sort through the competing
offers and federal procurement
procurement rules while under pressure
to give President Trump something to
announce hey with all of that said
President Trump got himself in a little
bit of hot water yesterday because he
suggested that we don't actually need
40,000 or 30,000 ventilators he said you
go into major hospitals sometimes and
they will have two ventilators and all
of a sudden
saying can we order 30,000 ventilators
people in the media again fulminating
over president from saying that but
there's been no information that Trump
is actually denying New York what it
needs like Cuomo is calling him up and
saying I need 30,000 ventilators Trump
saying I don't believe you Stu they
they're giving them all the ventilators
they can get their hands on I mean Cuomo
himself has said that at this point yeah
as far as where this is all going dr.
Anthony foul she did say yesterday we're
not going to work by Easter right
there's no information to suggest the
we're all back at work by Easter that is
very likely I mean that that'd be April
12th it's already March 27th we're
likely not to hit the peak according to
any study until around Easter that is
the most likely time when we hit the
peak number of cases in the United
States according to sort of the pandemic
when the pandemic studies the pandemic
methodologies that are being applied
here's dr. Anthony found she's saying no
you know Easter is a little bit
optimistic I think that the president
was trying to do he was making an
aspirational projection to give people
some hope but he's listening to us when
we say we really got to reevaluate it in
real time and any decision we make has
to be based on the data I mean you know
the numbers that you showed when you
have a situation when the cases today
compared to tomorrow is increased
dramatically and then the next day's
entries grammatically that's no time to
pull back okay and I think that
everybody gets that right Trump was
expressing an optimistic date when he
said April 12th he was not saying we're
definitely open by Easter but you know
have your eye on the ball as to when we
reopen that that is a good thing now
it's time for a little bit of good news
so president Trump yesterday he did an
interview on Sean Hannity's Fox News
program and he suggested that he thinks
the mortality rate for this thing is
well below 1% now just a few weeks ago
that was verboten you weren't allowed to
say that all right just a few weeks ago
if you said this they claim that you
were downplaying the virus they said
that no whu-oh is saying it's 3% they're
saying that it's 4% in some areas look
at Italy where it's 8% or 9% the reality
is it probably is below 1% right likely
the death rate on this thing is the
mortality rate is below 1% it may be
well below 1% again we had on a doctor
from Stanford University yesterday and
he suggests and he suggested that this
thing might look a lot more like actual
influenza death rates then it looks like
SARS or mirrors which is likely as I say
before I think that the best day to
suggest the dead is the case here's
President Trump saying I think the
mortality rate is well below 1% one
thing that I can say that's really good
the mortality rate is much much better
in our way then I was then people were
thinking at the beginning because you
were hearing three four or five percent
and now with all of the testing and all
of the things you see the people who
died you take a look at the people you
know I think you're talking about very
significantly under 1% and I think
that's a tremendous that's a tremendous
thing and he's right about this so again
if you said this a few weeks ago if you
said that the death rate looked a lot
more like flu and a lot less like SARS
and mirrors then you were considered a
denier there's one of the problems with
fast developing scientific consensus is
it very often they're happening before
you actually have the data in right and
by the way Anthony foul she was saying
this like in late February when February
28th there was a piece that he wrote
along with Robert Redfield who is one of
the heads of the CDC and Clifford Lane
and he wrote this it was it was accessed
last on March 26th 2020 and in that
article he suggested that the best data
suggest the overall clinical
consequences of kovat 19 may ultimately
be more akin to those of a severe
seasonal influenza which has a case
fatality rate of approximately 0.1% or a
pandemic influenza similar to 50 set in
1957 or 1968 like that was actually
called the Hong Kong flu in 1957 rather
than a disease similar to SARS or
mirrors which had case fatality rates of
nine to ten percent and 36 percent
respectively so this has actually been a
fairly well known scientific consensus
it sounds like for several weeks is that
this thing is far less deadly than
originally thought but if you said this
in the media then you were labeled a
denier okay well the good news about
that is that means that when we see vast
swathes of people getting this thing yes
some of those people are going to die
but it ain't gonna be three or four
percent and if you get it the chances
that you're going to die of it unless
you are vulnerable prior unless you're
elderly unless you have a pre-existing
condition are pretty low now again that
doesn't mean that on an absolute level
like it just the way stats works you may
be the one right okay so this is why
everybody should still be you know
concerned but if you if you're just
taking a lottery and the rates are point
one percent like like the influence
that means that one out of every
thousand people is going to die of
acquiring this thing right you acquire
coronavirus you die that is one out of
every thousand people if you're a point
one percent well if you're the one it
doesn't matter what the right was if
you're the one your right is a hundred
percent right but if you are if you are
just taking your odds it makes a very
big difference if somebody said to you
you have a you have we're going to put a
gun to your head and now you have to
pick one marble and there's there's a
thousand marbles one of them is black
the other 999 are white and if you pick
the black one you're gonna die you would
feel a lot more confident in picking the
marbles than you would if it were ten
times that right if there were a hundred
black marbles in there or if there are
even ten black marbles in there out of
out of a thousand so that is some actual
good news and it does raise the question
as to whether the lockdown measures that
have been taken are actually the most
effective and by the way I'm not the
only person who's been asking that I
mean Andrew Cuomo is asking that he
Andrew Cuomo the governor of New York he
said maybe we shouldn't have done a
total shutdown maybe this wasn't
actually the best policy and maybe maybe
we were over the top and how we did this
entire thing now I think a hard stop was
necessary because we didn't have the
data at that point but as the data comes
in we're going to have to reassess this
and we get to that reassessment in just
one second but the the kind of new
fangled consensus is that the most
catastrophic studies here are overstated
that the the the kind of estimates that
huge numbers of americans can die
hundreds of thousands of americans are
gonna die that is probably a wild over
estimate deborah birx who's leading up
the coronavirus effort on behalf of the
administration
she base she basically lectured the
media yesterday saying you guys keep
suggesting that all of our ICU beds are
gonna run out that everybody's gonna be
sharing a ventilator that there's gonna
be mass death in the streets cats and
dogs living together the end of the
world and deborah birx who's well
respected okay she has served in
administrations both Republicans and
Democrats she said this yesterday
members of the media went nuts they were
very upset about this how could deborah
birx chide the media for citing the
worst case scenario statistics how could
she do that and she was like well
because those probably aren't gonna
materialize maybe you should actually
give some nuanced information here was
Debra Brooks just staring into the media
yesterday please for the reassurance of
people around the world to wake up this
morning and look at people talking about
creating DNR situations do not
settees situations for patients there is
no situation in the United States right
now that warrants that kind of
discussion you can be thinking about it
in a hospital certainly many hospitals
talk about this on a daily basis but to
say that to the American people to make
the implication that when they need a
hospital bed it's not gonna be there or
when they need that ventilator it's not
gonna be there
we don't have an evidence of that right
now okay so I mean that is a pretty
stunning statement right the media keeps
saying as I say they keep saying in a
worst-case scenario we're gonna run out
of heads ICU beds there won't be any
there won't be any hospital beds we're
not gonna have any ventilators you're
gonna go into the hospital is gonna look
like Italy we're gonna shuttle you off
into a hallway somewhere where you choke
for breath and then die right and
Deborah Brooks is like um guys you might
want to wait on it that way it's not
just deborah birx
it's not just deborah birx bill de
blasio right who's been as
panic-stricken as any public leader in
America truly right bill de blasio came
out today and he said you know you guys
keep talking about this protective gear
shortage for healthcare workers in New
York and it doesn't exist he said
there's a lot of fear I don't blame any
healthcare professional look what
they're having to deal with
he says the truth is we have again the
supplies for this weekend next week we
have to make sure every hospital is
getting them to their extraordinary
heroic medical personnel but we've but
they do exist right here so the the by
the way Chris Andrew Cuomo again said
the same thing Andrew Cuomo said we do
have the personal protective equipment
in New York but if you watch the media
it's all nurses and doctors wearing
trash bags shortage of medical equipment
everybody is gonna die in the hospital
after being coughed on by a patient with
corona virus everyone's gonna have to
share events later we're gonna have to
convert all the CPAP machines mass
casualties Burke said we were reassured
after meeting with colleagues in New
York there are still ICU beds remaining
they're still significant over a
thousand or 2,000 ventilators that have
not been used yet she said like stop
exaggerating this thing she says you
could be thinking about it in a hospital
certainly many hospitals talk about it
on a daily basis but to say that to the
American people to make the implication
that when there's a hospital but it's
not going to be there we don't have
evidence she said there's no reality on
the ground where we can see that 60 to
70 percent of Americans are gonna get
infected in the next 8 to 12 weeks I
just want to be clear about that
so when people say like a huge
percentage of Americans will be in
or have been infected that may happen in
the future but not necessarily right now
okay and by the way I trust dr. deborah
birx more than I trust the people at the
New York Times and until five seconds
ago it was people at the New York Times
saying we should trust Brooks and not
Trump so which is it guys
now what I'm saying is is replicating
what Falchi said and I'm quoting foul
and I'm quoting Burks and yet if you if
you quote them now this is controversial
like Burk started trending on Twitter
yesterday for having the temerity to
point out that people are getting
panic-stricken about this and that the
media are deliberately stoking the panic
which is like again best best data
suggests that there will be a lot of
people who die from this we don't have
the data I mean this has been my
constant complaint we don't have the
data from the New York government from
the federal government as to how many
ventilators they actually think we're
gonna need what are the priors what are
the inputs in that model if it's bad
data in it's bad data out how many
ventilators we are going to need that we
don't already have how those ventilators
are gonna be deployed how much the New
York City system is going to be
overwhelmed are there outlying systems
where people can be shifted out of
hospital beds this is happening by the
way in New York City people are being
moved out of beds that are not ICU beds
just kind of normal hospital beds and
they're being moved to other sort of
medical centers so we can make room but
the Javits Center is being converted for
normal hospital beds right you had a
surgery two weeks ago and you're still
recovering from the surgery but you
don't need ICU care so we're converting
over a lot of the beds that are in
hospitals where you can have better
treatments and we're taking we're
setting up hospital rooms and Stauffer
for people who are just sort of in
recovery but all you need is an IV which
all that stuff is being done in real
time and again there's still serious
questions to be asked about the models
that are being applied in the first
place right the Netherlands has been
applying completely different models
according to science magazine Martin
entering and coupe form it writing they
say with Cova 19 modeling takes on
life-and-death importance they say the
Netherlands has so far chosen a softer
set of measures than most Western
European countries it was late to close
at schools and restaurants they didn't
order a full lockdown in a March 17th
speech Prime Minister Mark Rutte a
rejected working endlessly to contain
the virus and shutting down the country
completely instead he opted for
controlled spread while making sure the
health system isn't swamps with Cova 19
patients which by the way is sort of the
South Korean model kind of he called on
the public to respond to respect the
government's expertise on how to thread
that needle
the the predictions put out by Jacques
Ellul Inga whose computer simulations
are being used by the National Institute
for Public Health in the environment
over in the Netherlands right his
simulations predict the number of
infected people needing hospitalization
will taper off as of next week so there
are some pretty stark differences
between models where you had the
Imperial College model that was
suggesting that half a million people
were gonna die if there were no measures
taken in the UK I talked about this
yesterday and then yesterday the the
head of that study suggested that thanks
to the lockdown models and then he sort
of kind of slid in there and also thanks
to the lower death rate he was
predicting now that there might be only
20,000 people who died in the UK that
was not him throwing out his old model
is him saying them well if we apply like
heavy tamp down then we are going to
dramatically lower the carbon that's
pretty dramatic lowering of the curve
from 500,000 to 20,000 but even his
models are under pressure
Oxford put out a model that suggested
the death rates were even lower than
that the Netherlands has put our models
suggesting that this thing is gonna peak
next week malinga is confident that the
number of new infections caused by each
person when no control measures are
taken is just over 2 he trusts data
showing that 3 to 6 days elapse between
the moment someone is infected and the
time they start to infect others will
Linga says he is least confident about
the susceptibility of various age groups
but he also suggests that we are not
going to be overwhelmed in the
Netherlands ok again there's this
assumption that every case is gonna be
worst case like Italy or Spain but the
evidence that every case is gonna be
like Italy or Spain is just not there
right it's not there at this point maybe
it will be maybe it will be we keep
hearing that it's about to happen in New
York City that's why I say that tsunami
may be coming
we just don't know because it's hard to
know whom to believe the story seems to
be changing on a daily basis right the
media are not particularly trustworthy
in their tone and tenor right they're
bringing you best available information
but so much of it is anecdotal the New
York Times every day is printing stories
about a doctor or unnerve says we're
being overwhelmed at a hospital and then
you go to the hospital administration
and the hospital administration is like
now we're we're ok I mean we're
stretched and restrained but we're
handling it by the way even in Italy new
coronavirus cases are actually slowing
according to Chico Harlan and Stefano
Petrelli over at the Washington Post
Italy's nationwide lockdown is showing
the first small signs of pay off the
number of coronavirus cases is still
rising but at the lowest day on teh pace
since the outbreak began
wh Oh calls the slowdown encouraging the
health chief in the hardest-hit region
says there's light at the end of the
tunnel Italy was the first Western
country to contend with a mass outbreak
and order a lockdown now they're trying
to figure out how long the restrictions
could last but the bottom line is that
even Italy which has been overwhelmed is
starting to tamp down and and and move
move beyond the day-to-day increases in
the virus all of which is a very very
good thing
President Trump spoke yesterday by the
way about the resources that are being
applied in the United States he says
we're shipping tons of resources like
people are pretending then we're not
getting masks out to people we're not
getting personal protective equipment
out to people that's not true here's
President Trump at a press conference
yesterday talking about the numbers of
resources being shipped all over the
country FEMA has shipped over 9 million
n95 masks 20 million face masks 3.1
million face shields nearly 6,000
ventilators 2.6 million gowns 14.6
million gloves and we're sending more
every day and we've got tremendous
amounts of equipment coming in ok so it
again the notion that the federal
government is doing nothing is just not
true and that that is a real media bias
I'm gonna get to more media bias in just
one second President Trump said last
night
on Hannity that hospitals are actually
being set up in New York City resources
are being brought to bear right so this
is the panic in other words maybe over
it maybe it's not but maybe overstated
it deborah birx who I trust a lot more
than the New York Times is suggesting
that the panic is overstated I trust her
more than I trust the New York Times
doctor foul she has not made any public
statements so far as I'm aware that all
of the systems in New York are going to
be completely overwhelmed death in the
streets we're gonna have to choose
between old patients and young patients
this is gonna be Italy here's President
Trump yesterday so we're building
hospitals in New York we're building for
hospitals for medical centers and many
other things we've developed and sent
thousands of thousands of ventilators
and hopefully they're gonna do well so
again resources are being brought to
bear and this does raise the question
okay so if we have raised as I've said
all along if we have flatten the curve
enough and we have raised that line of
medical resources enough that the line
now clears the flattened curve then
we have to start having conversations
about how to get back to work and maybe
that is not applied on an even basis
across the United States because not
every place is a hot spot center of this
outbreak in New York City is a hot spot
sensor is the Moines Iowa right the LA
so far has been really trailing New York
is LA exactly the same as New York I
mean major cities are gonna be the
epicenters of this stuff but how about
outlying rural areas are we seeing mass
death in the rural areas which by the
way is where you sort of would expect to
see male stuff considering hospital
resources are far less there are tons of
counties in the United States that don't
have a single hospital there may be
neighboring counties that have the
hospital but rural outlying areas they
don't actually have the medical
resources being brought to bear but
you're not seeing mass death in those
areas so in one second we're going to
get to the question of when we reopen
because what you're gonna see it's
pretty incredible is that Andrew Cuomo
and Donald Trump are basically saying
the same thing and Donald Trump is
getting just his ass kicked by the media
and the and and meanwhile Andrew Cuomo
is getting his ass kissed by the media
right Trump is getting his ass kicked
and Cuomo is getting his ass kissed and
they're saying exactly the same thing
about how we reopen this thing how we
how we open this thing back up and that
is because the media's desire for a
binary narrative in which President
Trump is responsible for every cruel ill
of the United States and Trump is
sitting there with his arms crossed
putting on the Trump frown and saying to
people yeah not gonna give ventilators I
don't even care I mean leg ventilators
and litters are bad like that that's not
happening
he and Cuomo are saying almost identical
things and the media is treating them as
though they're saying things that are
separated by 180 degrees and just a lie
and get to that in one second first it
is indeed that glorious time of the week
when I give a shout out to a daily wire
subscriber today it's tiller on
Instagram he knows what it takes to get
through the wall work wake in the pic
tiller is sporting an American worker
trucker hat while holding the world's
greatest beverage vessels in front of an
eye chart that hilariously reads Epstein
did not kill himself that's true if you
can see the post caption reads making
parts for the Apache helicopter can be
exhausting but I'm able to work 50-plus
hours weekly thanks to my refreshing
leftist cheers tumblr always refilling
sometimes hot sometimes cold always
delicious hashtag leftist ears hashtag
daily where hashtag American workers
hashtag us a hashtag hot or cold - tag
do work hashtag thank God it's Friday
first of all thank you to all of the
folks in the supply lines thank you to
all the folks in the trucking industry
who are doing hard work each and every
day to make sure their stuff the
groceries
making sure this
country's still moving you see folks
this is why you need to become a daily
wire member don't take it from me take
it from a man making the vital
components of an incredible attack
helicopter that supports the greatest
military the world has ever known
and also my personal gender identity
attack Apache attack helicopter thanks
for the pick teller keep up the good
work also if you haven't had a chance to
see some of our new content called
all-access live you should head over to
daily wire.com and check it out
Jeremy boring and I kicked it off last
week all of the other hosts have done
live streams over it's daily where I
come look we're gonna continue all this
week at 8 p.m. Eastern 5 p.m. Pacific
basically it's really just casual we
hang out I literally have no program
when I come on into all access live so
I'll just do whatever I feel like
earlier this week I just started playing
Brahms on the pro I don't know why and
it was fun so just come over and hang
out with us I know listen we're all
isolated we're all a little bit lonely
this really sucks ok no matter how you
slice it it sucks I'm glad we're safe
but this does suck a lot so come over to
daily wire and join the community and
hang out with us I think the live
streams are great not just for our
viewers but for us over here as well
makes us all feel better so thank you
from the bottom of our hearts and from
our team to yours for becoming members
the show is intended for our all access
members long term during the national
emergency we've opened it up to all of
our members in doing so we've
accelerated the launch so please let us
know what you think of it also if you're
around at 8 p.m. Eastern 5:00 p.m.
Pacific tonight join me the famous Ben
Shapiro on all-access live show over at
Daley wire.com also check out this
Sunday this Sunday
our Sunday special should be a pretty
special Sunday we're having on vice
president pence and dr. deborah birx
we're gonna be asking them some
questions on coronavirus and the path
this thing is going to take the media
coverage and China we're gonna run the
gamut with them so make sure to tune in
on Sunday that will be available to all
people whether you are a subscriber or
not head on over to tailee where to come
anyway and subscribe we are the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
okay so as I say as I've been saying the
media's coverage of this thing has just
been a bleep show and there's a reason
that Gallup has a pullout that shows of
all the American institutions faith and
all of them has gone up in the
presidency even in Congress in the
police like it except the media people
still hate the media they think the
media are lying to them why well maybe
it's because the media are wildly biased
and insane probably it's because of that
okay I'll give you an example so
yesterday Andrew Cuomo governor of New
York write widely held by the media to
be the greatest of all possible leaders
which honestly I found a little bit
weird because Gavin Newsom has basically
done exactly the same thing as Andrew
Cuomo but nobody ever talked about Gavin
Newsom out in my home state of
California and Andrew Cuomo was late to
the game right he has shifted his he has
shifted his narrative somewhat right
bill de blasio was saying we need a full
shutdown and combos like I'm not doing a
full shutdown and then he five minutes
later is like you know what maybe we
need a full shutdown
well now Andrew Cuomo is saying maybe we
shouldn't have done a total shutdown
maybe we should have done this in parts
we had to do what we had to do on sort
of a catch as catch can basis which at
least he's honest about that I think the
real reason that Cuomo is getting high
marks is cuz in these TV pressors he
seems to be authentic and honest which
again is all the media care about it's
all performance art for the media but in
any case Andrew Cuomo says maybe we
shouldn't have done a total shutdown
which is weird because when Trump says
this sort of thing he gets ripped up and
down what we did was we closed
everything down that was our public
health strategy just closed everything
all businesses all workers young people
old people short people told people's
every school closed everything
if you rethought that or had time to
analyze that public health strategy I
don't know that you would say quarantine
everyone I don't even know that that was
the best public health policy and then
there's Cuomo acknowledging full on they
maybe we should have considered other
public health policies and this is one
of the problems is that in the middle of
a panic which this basically isn't maybe
for a good reason the easiest thing to
do is try to hit somebody with as hit
the policy with a blunt instrument right
that's what this is this giant bailout
package was or stimulus but whatever you
want to call it really isn't the bailout
it really isn't even a stimulus it's
more like a shoring up bill that is
hitting hitting a button with a blunt
instruments
hammer and hitting a nail and the nail
may be tiny the hammer may be huge and
the same thing is true with these sort
of lockdown thing as I say I'm not anti
the lockdown I'm just saying that as
more data comes out we need to seriously
reconsider exactly how we go about
getting back to our daily business and
how we go about getting back to life I
say that people rip me up and down
you're not taking this you're not taking
this seriously I know if Andrew Cuomo
says the exact same thing and people are
like oh man what a genius I mean wow
like he's really being serious about
this thing here is Andrew Cuomo saying
overtime maybe some people can go back
to work how do you modify the public
health strategy to make it smarter from
a public health point of view but also
starts to get you back to work younger
people can go back to work people who
have resolved can go back to work people
who once we get this antibody tests show
that they had the virus and they
resolved can go back to work that's how
I think you do it it's not we're gonna
either do public health or we're gonna
do economic development development
restarting we have to do both okay
president some said exactly the same
thing yesterday like exactly the same
thing almost word-for-word so president
Trump yesterday said listen we can open
parts open up parts of the country we're
gonna need to do that on a case-by-case
basis in fact the Trump administration
issued guidelines for classifying US
counties by coronavirus risk which makes
perfect sense this is an enormous
country
okay the risk in Sweden is not the same
as the risk in France is not the same as
the risk in Italy all of those countries
are classifying their coronavirus risks
differently by the way the UK quietly
late last week downgraded the the
deadliness of the virus itself right
even in the UK where they are deeply
worried they'd called it a high-risk
disease they changed that very quietly
late last week okay but it's being
treated differently all over the
continent it's being treated differently
all over the world the United States is
a very very large chunk of territory to
suggest that we have to treat
coronavirus exactly the same way in Salt
Lake City Utah as we do in New York City
is really kind of ridiculous and the
Trump administration pointed this out
right according to Rebecca Bala House
reporting for The Wall Street Journal
the Trump administration is planning to
issue guidelines categorizing counties
across the nation as high-risk medium
risk or low risk to help state and local
authorities decide whether to bolster or
relax social distancing measures instead
to intended to combat the the
coronavirus in a letter to governor's on
Thursday President Trump said the
administration's growing testing
capabilities would enable it to publish
in
consultation with public health
officials and scientists criteria for
classifying counties by risk in the
hopes that some parts of the country may
be able to return to work sooner than
others
he wrote this new information will drive
the next phase in our war against this
invisible enemy as we enhance protection
against the virus Americans across the
country are hoping the day will soon
arrive when they can resume their normal
economic social and religious lives ok
and this was immediately this was
immediately seized on by the media
Trump Trump doesn't care about humans he
wants them all to die he's up the same
thing as Cuomo he's just saying we're
going to have to treat different
populations differently based on where
they are and what the risk is to them
why is that in any way unreasonable it's
a hundred percent reasonable every
single major world leader is considering
exactly that thing in a briefing later
on Thursday Trump said he intended to
start the process of relaxing social
distancing guidelines pretty soon said
the administration might Taylor
guidelines to specific parts of the
country said our people want to go back
to work I'm hearing it loud and clear
from everybody they don't want to sit
around and wait so here as president
from yesterday he said a couple of
things again this is very much in line
with what Andrew Cuomo is saying it's
just the one Trump says it's bad because
he's an orange person and when Andrew
Cuomo says that it's very good because
he doesn't like the orange person here's
President Trump yesterday saying we're
gonna have to think about opening up
parts of the country but again we're
gonna do this on a piecemeal basis the
end result is we got to get back to work
and I think we can start by opening up
certain parts of the country you know
with farm belt certain parts of the
Midwest other other places but I think
that as an example you go to Texas there
are places in Texas great governor Greg
Abbott there are places in Texas where
you know this a tremendously big state
that aren't impacted by this so I think
we can open up sections quadrants and
then just keep keep them going until the
whole country is opened up but we have
to open up the people want to get back
to work they want to get back oh no I
mean that's that wow I mean he said that
Texas is a really big state which it is
okay it takes you look if you were gonna
drive across Texas like widthwise
horizontally how long would that take
you called Colton's from Texas that that
would take you I'm it would take you 15
hours probably yeah 15 hours right don't
take forever it is a huge state of
course and by the way if you've ever
been to Texas you're driving for long
stretches of territory where there's
like
housed a cow right the notion that we're
gonna treat you know some podunk town in
Texas the same way that you treat Dallas
or Houston is obviously absurd Trump
isn't saying anything wrong there people
were like well that means he's gonna
open up the entire country he's telling
he's encouraging everybody in New York
to go to Shea Stadium and hang out with
each other and make out he's not doing
any of that stuff what are you talking
about he's saying the same kind of stuff
is everybody else right Trump says by
the way that social distancing will
remain after coronavirus much of the
guidelines like shaking hands maybe
people aren't gonna be shaking hands
anymore you know Tony had mentioned to
me Tony foul cheese the other day that I
don't think he was would be too upset
with the concept of not shaking hands he
was saying that the fluid cut down the
regular fluidly cut down by quite a bit
if we didn't do that if we didn't shake
hands use a regular flow of which you
know you have a lot of deaths and a lot
of problems with that when we're open as
soon as we open that doesn't mean you're
gonna stop with the guidelines you'll
still try and distance yourself maybe
not to the same extent because you have
to lead a life okay well again what is
he saying that's so wrong I mean he's
explicitly saying that social distancing
is good so the New York Times ran a
headline yesterday or was CNN rather
there in a headline saying foul she
encourages social distancing well Trump
talks about other Trump he's encouraging
social distancing he's saying maybe we
shouldn't shake hands every and by the
way I'm totally on board with that I
really am like shaking hands as a
general practice is kind of gross it's
it you are sharing terms with with lots
of people and that's been true no matter
no matter what the point here is that
the media coverage of Cuomo who's saying
the same stuff as Trump is glowing the
coverage of Trump is very bad but
everybody's sort of saying the same
thing and everybody is also saying
underlying all of this that we're all
waiting for more data so here's the deal
let's wait for the data let's get all
the resources where they need to be and
then let's wait for the data by the end
of next week we're going to know an
awful lot more I thought frankly we were
gonna know an awful lot more by the end
of this week I mean given the
projections
I thought by today by like this Friday
we were gonna know whether the health
systems were gonna be overwhelmed it
looks like it's lagged a bit maybe
because of this lockdown probably
because at least in large part because
of the lockdown but we're gonna find out
by the end of next week certainly by the
week after that we're gonna be finding
out exactly how bad this thing is going
to be because by pretty much everybody's
estimation early April mid April
start to see this thing and start to
pick up in terms of tempo and peak and
then the question is going to be did we
have the resources that were necessary
on hand are we Italy or do we end up
just being the UK right where again the
new estimate suggests that the health
system will not be overwhelmed now with
all of that said the Democrats are
moving swiftly to try and make to try
and use crisis in order to push forward
even more spending to Nancy Pelosi who
held up a bill that her own party had
helped negotiate over the weekend is
supposed to vote on this thing today
right the house is supposed to vote on
this thing today Nancy Pelosi says well
this is just the beginning we're gonna
spend even more and more and more and
more we literally are expending six
trillion dollars six trillion dollars to
put that by way of contrast the entire
American economy on a yearly basis about
20 trillion dollars we're spend about
1/3 of the entire American economy in
like a week seriously on on this thing
and answer blows like but we can spend
more we should at least I'm right and
it's like okay really it feels like
people are very uncomfortable
people are extremely uncomfortable with
not being able to simply go back to
their pre-existing sub positions about
the way the world works and so as
quickly as possible people move back
into their fighting corners and they
wait for the situation to emerge where
they can go back to fighting the way
that they are used to fighting whenever
there's a pandemic whenever there's
something brutal that happened on 9/11
where there's a major crisis people get
out of their corners for just a minute
and they think to themselves okay how do
I help out my neighbors how do we craft
a policy that works for right now how
would you and then as soon as humanly
possible we're not comfortable in that
space we're comfortable going back to
our corners and so you see people like
Nancy Pelosi immediately swivel into
green eutteum you see Nancy Pelosi
swivel engine we need more spending and
and and you see Republicans meanwhile
swivel back into their prior suit like
everybody swivels back into their
practice Nelson I agree with the
Republican priors obviously a lot more
than the Democrat priors but how about
this how about we just wait I know it's
the hardest thing to do it's the hardest
thing to do in life but we don't have
enough data to be jumping on let's spend
trillions more dollars and we also don't
have enough hard data at this point say
reopen the American economy wholesale
and and I don't think tons of people are
saying the latter I think a lot of
people are saying the former here's
Nancy Pelosi claiming we need to spend
even more and more and more and more for
evermore we had bigger direct payments
in our
I don't think we've seen the end of
direct payments this is an emergency
a challenge to the conscience as well as
the budget of our country and every
dollar that we spend is an investment in
the lives in the livelihood of the
American people we can go bigger
especially now the interest rates are
even lower than the ten at the time of
the tax scam we can go even bigger even
bigger that how endlessly what are you
just to inflate the currency who's gonna
buy our bonds like this is it basically
the Democrats are in real time now going
to try according ansi pelosi to apply
elizabeth warren's modern monetary
theory which suggests that you can just
float debt in a just interminably just
forever you can just continue to take
out dead end dead end dead end debt well
that assumes there's an appetite for the
debt who the hell has the money to pay
for the debt right now do you think
Britain is gonna be buying American
bonds on mass how about China you think
they're gonna be buying American mounds
by the way breaking news China had
started reopening all of their movie
theaters weirdly they are now closing
all of their movie theaters again so
what do you think you think the
coronavirus thing is done in China you
think we've been given accurate
statistics about China I think not I
think not so all of this happy talk from
Nancy Pelosi let's go back to our priors
let's completely remake the world
economy like Bernie would want like how
about this how about we deal with the
crisis at hand and we all get out of
those corners and we deal with it and
then we start figuring out how we go
back to a life that happened before
because I'll tell you what right now
life is a lot worse than it was three
weeks ago a lot worse than it was four
weeks ago how about we set our sights on
let's get back to where we were four
weeks ago before you decide that you
want to fundamentally transform the
American economy along your your
ridiculous big government lines how
about that let's start there
okay time for a quick thing that I hate
so speaking of people who are who are
seeking to go back to their priors there
is this bizarre bizarre attempt every
time there is a national crisis by local
leaders to shift the responsibility onto
the national leaders and I recall this
happening during Hurricane Katrina when
Mayor Ray Nagin who is the mayor of New
Orleans did not evacuate the city when
he was told that he probably should
evacuate the city and then the city was
swamped and then he blamed President
Bush and suggested the President Bush
was a racist and that was Bush's fault
that the resources weren't made
available even though he was the mayor
and it really was his responsibility to
clear the thing I remember that I think
the the governor at the time was
Kathleen Blanco I remember she said sort
of the same thing it's always the the
impetus is always on local leaders to
try and blame national leadership for
your own failures well this week the New
Orleans mayor blamed President Trump for
not shutting down Mardi Gras the mayor's
name is Cantrell and she suggested that
President Trump is to blame for the city
of New Orleans not shutting down Mardi
Gras here she was on CNN with Wolf
Blitzer you're saying no one from the
federal government came to you and urge
you to at least cancel or postpone Mardi
Gras that's absolutely correct and not
only that it was backed up with the
response of our national leader when
it's not taken seriously at the federal
level it's very difficult to transcend
down to the local level in making these
decisions um what what her name is
Latoya Cantrell the mayor of New Orleans
now last I checked she's the mayor of
New Orleans Donald Trump is not the
mayor of New Orleans you know who's the
mayor of Los Angeles Eric Garcetti not
Donald Trump at least Garcetti isn't out
there trying to claim that it's Trump's
fault that he allowed the LA Marathon to
happen like two weeks ago on a Sunday in
the middle of the pandemic you know this
this woman going out there and
suggesting that she needed a personal
phone by the way you know it would have
happened if Trump had called her up and
said you know you really should shut
down Mardi Gras on the basis of this
coronavirus pandemic in mid-february
when by the way half the media was still
not taking this seriously like at all I
mean really like voxcom ran a piece on
January 31st about why this was gonna be
no worse than the seasonal flu Hey for
her to suggest that if Trump had called
her up and been like I let you shut down
Mardi Gras shouldn't been like mr.
president you can't do that right like
of course that's what she would have
said she would have said like are you
kidding why would I shut down Mardi Gras
she's the mayor Tate you have your local
Lee
you blew it it's cuz you blew it why are
we pretending the President of the
United States to some godlike figure who
can descend from on high and then order
you to do all the things you're supposed
to do as a local leader to get same crap
from Bill DeBlasio you're the mayor of a
major city you tried to run for
president on the basis of that it seems
to me you should be able to make some
local decisions weird because it seems
like there are some local leaders who
did make some of those local decisions
to shut down major public events but her
blaming Trump for the outbreak in New
Orleans is just like everything is
Trump's fault
or alternatively again everybody
shifting back to their their priors the
New York Times ran a piece today called
the road to coronavirus hell was paved
by evangelicals evangelicals okay let me
just ask a question so these centers of
the outbreak that we've seen thus far
are China famous for its huge
evangelical Christian population China I
mean just tons of evangelicals over
there it's like it's like a convention
of religious evangelical Christians over
in China a communist atheist country and
then Italy again hugely famous for
having tons of evangelicals it in Italy
now like it's the home of the Catholic
Church or anything like it's all
evangelicals over intimately and in the
United States at New York City where
evangelicals just swarm New York City I
know like probably 2/3 of the population
of New York City is evangelical of
course I'm being a little sarcastic here
and by a little I mean a lot but if
you're blaming evangelicals for the
outbreak of coronavirus by the way these
are the same people presumably who would
say that if you say Chinese virus is
very very racist if you if you blame it
on the government of China very racist
but you blame the evangelicals
evangelicals are sitting over here like
what that what in the world thank us
seriously but the New York Times ran
this piece anyway because nothing says
unifying the country like blaming
evangelicals for coronavirus Catherine
Stewart the author of the power
worshippers inside the dangerous rise of
religious nationalism
so her priors are fairly well
established she says Donald Trump rose
to power with the determined assistance
of a movement that denies science bashes
government and prioritized loyalty over
professional expertise in the current
crisis we are all reaping what that
movement has sown at least since the
19th century when the pro-slavery
theologian Robert Lewis Dabney attacked
the physical sciences as theories of
unbelief hostility to science has
characterized the more extreme forms of
religious nationalism in the United
States today the hard core of climate
deniers is concentrated among people who
identify
religiously conservative Republicans and
some leaders of the Christian
nationalist movement like those allied
with Cornwall Alliance for the steward
of creation which has denounced
environmental science as the cult of the
Green Dragon cast environmentalism as an
alternative and false theology this
denial of science and critical thinking
among religious ultra-conservatives now
haunts the American response to the
coronavirus crisis um what I'm mm-hmm
just gonna point out is Anthony Fauci
who stands next to trump like every
single day on a podium is is that guy
like an evangelical Christian science
and I how about deborah birx how about
jerome Adams the the guy who's the
Surgeon General that doctor and all
those guys are evangelicals Trump Trump
is listening to people who deny science
totally while also recommending what his
scientists tell them on March 15th says
this columnist Guillermo Maldonado who
calls himself an apostle and hosted mr.
Trump earlier this year to campaign
events at his Miami mega church urged
his congregants to show up for worship
services in person do you believe God
would bring his people to his house to
be contagious with the virus of course
not he said okay so your best evidence
that Trump is following evangelical
science deniers your best evidence is
that a guy who hosted Trump at a
campaign event earlier this year said a
thing now that Wow
strong evidence New York Times really
really do an amazing work over here
blaming evangelicals for the rise of
coronavirus
religious nationalism says this
columnist has brought to American
politics the conviction that our
political differences our battle between
absolute evil and absolute good only a
heroic leader free from the scruples of
political correctness can save the
righteous from the damned fealty to the
cause is everything fidelity to the
facts means nothing
perhaps this is why many Christian
nationalist leaders greeted the news of
the coronavirus as an insult to their
chosen leader okay honestly this is so
tiresome it's so unbelievably tiresome
in the middle of in the middle of
pandemic how about you put aside your
hatred for evangelical Christians and
you just say listen we're all Americans
we're all in this together and we are
all waiting for the data to come out as
opposed to blame the Christians truly
insane truly insane stuff from the New
York Times but there you have it the New
York Times doing its best to divide the
country with their op-ed page in the
middle of a pandemic really solid stuff
there already
well we will be back here later to do
two additional hours of content
otherwise we will see
here on Monday for all of the updates in
the meantime tried to relax this weekend
try to hang out with your family if you
want to do something nice for a neighbor
fine I've got an elderly neighbor who
can't go out try to get them some
groceries or something call up some
friends make sure everybody is doing
okay I know there's some blood drives
going on so you might want to call your
local hospital because I know that there
are a lot of young people who can give
blood if you're the sooner they're shown
you can't get blood their blood
shortages around the country so that
would be a great thing to do my wife has
encouraged me to say that on the show so
I'd be remiss if I did not try to do
something good for the country this
weekend and not read the New York Times
and we will see you here on Sunday I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas
directed by Mike joiner executive
producer Jeremy boring supervising
producer Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling assistant director Pavel I
douse key technical producer Austin
Stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SIA vets audio is
mixed by micro Romina hair and makeup is
by Nika Geneva the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 25
you know the Matt Walsh oh it's not just
another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen